[Music]
good evening everyone stéphane donikian CEO and
co-founder of golem which is no longer a
start up but an innovative sme which will
celebrate its thirteen years
of existence at the end of December so we are an off
line spin ria  and we specialize in the
modeling and simulation of
individual and collective movements and behaviors of autonomous entities,
so whether they are humans,
animals, monsters, everything we can
imagine since our first use
was in the special effects and film sector.
animation cinema and video games
if we cutscenes from video games,
so today we are a
world leader in this sector and we
decided two years ago to carry out a
diversification to
enable the generation of
synthetic data and scenarios
for learning
artificial intelligence algorithms will be able to
generate a number of situations
and in this case for confidence
points and having simulated c
behaviors inside a city to allow
autonomous vehicles to be trained to
react to a certain number of situations,
we have recently seen again that it can
be accident-prone to have vehicles
with autonomy in
urban environments and that  we
cannot be satisfied with real data
for that we need
synthetic data and our job is
to be able to generate diversity
in synthetic data and to be able
to study either rare situations
or dangerous situations  and
therefore to be able to work on
the learning therefore of its pilots
autonomous of the vehicles outside it is not
necessarily that the vehicles we
also work with other companies
on learning the behavior of
users in shopping centers of
video surveillance including  there are also other
uses in
artificial intelligence but in the context of
trust - lyon will focus on
autonomous vehicles
thank
you thank you that the valves
[Applause]
[Music]